the first fantastic four movie and i
think you guys will agree with me that
dared to ask the question what would the
thing look like if you didn't wear pants
the whole time
and it answered
tom nina what upcoming marvel release
will have the biggest impact
on the mcu and why nina i defer to you
thank you sir i went through a few
things here because uh
in terms of the reveal in falcon of the
winter soldier of julia louis dreyfus
dreyfuss's character the contessa uh
there are possibilities for her i think
she was originally supposed to appear in
black widow is that correct that is my
understanding
that was i that was supposed to be her
mcu debut and then this came
first bite right because everything has
delayed yes
and so you know i think that there's a
lot of potential with such a
huge star uh to have some really good
crossover
with that but ultimately i the one i
hope has the most impact is actually uh
thor love and thunder
because we're gonna get to see the
return of natalie portman to the mcu
um and her character was really pretty
dull
in the first two thor movies but clearly
she has enough faith in take away ttg to
come back and
and you know pick that role back up but
she's also going to be female thor so
i'm really hoping that that has
long running ramifications in the entire
mcu i mean obviously
like there's those there's the real
world logistics of does natalie portman
want to commit like 10 years of her life
or something to
the universe you know because you know
robert downey jr and chris evans were
like
you know they're getting weary of it you
know there were reports away before they
did leave the franchise that they wanted
to
so i guess that remains to be seen but
i'm really hoping that her
female thor is like huge in the mcu i
mean literally and figuratively huge
literally i want her to just grow into a
colossus and kick thor
gigantic out yeah
i'm really looking forward to that movie
i think it's going to be really cool i
think that it'll be interesting to see
yeah you're right like
the main thor is going off into space
with the guardians of the galaxy
and so we're going to have this new thor
is she going to show up in avengers
5 is she going to show up in other
projects is there going to be
a long-term plan for natalie portman in
this mcu now that she's back and
more interested in participating i think
that that's a really good
point i think that's interesting yeah
yeah i'm really excited to see
where this goes yeah tom what do you
think
what is going to be the most impactful
project that marvel is going to be
putting out that's going to have the
biggest impact on the mcu control
well when we say impact what do we mean
i mean
we mean it's got to change the franchise
long lasting ramifications in some way
shape or form that's exactly what i'm
talking about brian
okay and i'd love to hear the word on
the same page yes no i agree and i think
that the only way to impact the
franchise in any meaningful way is to do
what
is to expand it right like more
characters we need to bring in more
characters than people love
uh specifically uh recognizable
characters
and that's why i think the fantastic
four is going to be the
the biggest and most impactful addition
to the mcu in the next several years
okay tell us why so it all goes back to
2015
right you remember the josh drank
fantastic four movie
i try not to yeah there were parts of it
that were good
there were parts of it that were good
the movie is overall
not good at all but it was the first
fantastic four
movie and i think you guys will agree
with me that dared to ask the question
what would the thing look like if you
didn't wear pants the whole time
and it answered it answered for an hour
and i want to say 27 minutes whatever
the cutoff is
for being an actual movie like in terms
of runtime
it answered that question in 2015
josh train's fantastic four movie and
see if you follow me here
included a promotional plan with the
denny's chain of diner restaurants
in which they introduced a new menu
called appropriately
the slamtastic four this included
meals like the human torch skillet
the thing burger and the dr doom lava
cake
let's assume that this is cannon let's
assume
that the menu is carrying over into the
mcu that would mean
that denny's is now part of the mcu and
do you know who loves denny's
tim allen from the first santa claus
movie that would mean
bringing in not just santa claus himself
but also i'm i'm failing to remember
the name of the actor the guy from
numbers what was his what was his name
uh david cremoels david crumult
we could bring david cremalts into the
mcu how would that not be the biggest
day of
all of our lives i would be into that i
am a big
fan of david cromoltz and his i've never
thought about david kermaltz's path to
the mcu but it's very clear to me now
now that we see it we can't see it no
guys i just bought a cork board it's not
ready yet but i'm gonna hang it up and
i'm gonna have
so many visual aids ready for the next
time that we do this oh man
as long as it says pepe sylvia on it
then we're good to go
can we back up a second though yeah and
sir and seriously ask
would anyone here actually eat something
called a thing burger
nobody did right no
a thing burger that's your
didn't name to public school and get hot
lunch ate anything that was called
a thing burger imagine being in
the the room with the marketers and say
okay we've got this great
fantastic four tie-in with denny's
we've got the doom lava cake the human
dude
lava cake human torch skill let me tell
you what we got right now we got a piece
of resistance
sandwich that looks like a rock
[Applause]
doesn't that sound good um i'm hungry
wow wow okay
so these are facts mine what do you
think
my pick thank you for asking tom i
should have waited
but i didn't because i'm so excited
because
my pick comes much sooner than fantastic
four
but it is tied to the fantastic
and it is ant-man 3 quantum mania
directed by peyton reed
here's why i think that ant-man 3 is
going to be the most
impactful movie for the mcu going
forward
for the foreseeable future in
ant-man and the wasp the second ant-man
movie
we find out that ant-man is gonna go
quantum the original ant-man is gonna
quantum rescue the original wasp from
the quantum realm
and do all kinds of shenanigans that way
then paul rudd's
scotland gets lost in the in the uh
trapped in the quantum realm at the end
of that movie
and comes back to life in avengers end
game he pops out of the van ant van
and using his knowledge and technology
of the quantum realm
is able to help the avengers pull off
the time heist
to get the infinity stones to bring back
everybody
i contend that ant-man 3
will similarly explore the quantum realm
and open up
the marvel multiverse
because if you can go through time
through the quantum realm you can also
probably go through different dimensions
and explore different realms and bring
in
characters like the fantastic four now
here's another thought i had the
fantastic four
is one of the oldest groups of marvel
superheroes
right outside of captain america and
human torch and a few others
like namor who haven't been introduced
yet the fantastic four
whole thing yeah fantastic thing
exactly is exploring exploring realms
outside of our knowledge what if you
have a story in which at the end of
ant-man
he comes into contact with the fantastic
four and they say
finally we're back you freed us
from our adventure in dimension
z or whatever and then everyone's like
we've never heard of you what
huh and then you get this
pre-established bunch of characters
that we get to be introduced to because
they've been lost and they're introduced
and you can play with all kinds of
things where because they left
their history was erased and time
started over i don't know you could do
something
but there's a way to connect the whole
marvel multiverse
maybe even bring in some of those former
cast members from those old fantastic
four movies maybe make them canon again
maybe don't make them canon and do
something different but you can still
introduce
all these great properties that way
that's what i kind of theorized they
were going to do in wine division and
then they didn't they were going to
somehow
bring in the multiverse so that's how i
think that ant-man 3 is going to be the
most influential one
they're going to be the ones that i love
the fantastic four and it's perfect
because i feel like ant-man is like this
very unassuming part of the mcu and i i
did not see
ant-man and the wasp when it was
originally released i kind of was like
whatever
and i skipped it and then uh a friend of
mine who
loves all things marvel when i told him
that he was like oh my god so you didn't
see the
the credits scene it so infinity war
makes no sense or like uh
or i guess that like end game made less
sense because i had not
yet seen that credit scene and so like
it's
it's kind of under the radar where like
you're like ant-man is that important
he's tiny but then it holds like the key
like you're saying to the entire entire
thing
true yeah but it kind of it unlocks like
so much you're i think you're
on to something really cool here i think
i am too
yeah yeah yeah
there's such a great comic book series
too uh that that like
revolves around uh reed richards and and
scott lang specifically ant-man's
relationship i
i don't know how much of it you could
fit into it but hey i don't know that
could be really
uh ff you ever read that i didn't read
ff
terrific uh mike allred and uh and uh
fractured this one right yes spectacular
so worth checking out
did you ever get a chance i will i do
have a chance yeah i work for looper
that's yeah all i do now
our job we don't work this is great yeah
no we can read cops
yeah it's called rules uh
so yeah that's my pick that's good
that's a fantastic idea that works
really really well yeah thank you
yeah kevin feige are you listening yeah
i mean i'll
i'll still work for looper but maybe you
could maybe we'll talk on the phone
yeah yeah shoot bryan a text kevin
because i
assume he doesn't have any of this
figured out yet and he's just waiting
for someone cool like me to go on
youtube or facebook or wherever you're
watching this
yeah and talk about his ideas for the
comic book movies
he needs the assist he's like not
getting by yeah
you're welcome you've been waiting for
someone just like me to do something
just like this there's no one else out
there doing this
this is very unique we talk about comic
books on the internet
yeah yeah yeah so anyway
that's the end of it thanks for joining
us please hit like and subscribe so you
don't miss a single episode